mercy pereira is struggling to keep the
home fires burning
for 35 years she has been making and
selling stringhoppers a popular sri
lankan staple
but with food prices skyrocketing
cooking gas and kerosene unavailable
she's struggling
i have to look after eight people i
manage all the expenses with what i make
even the water and electricity bills
if costs increase more than this i just
can't go on
mercy is not alone more sri lankans are
reeling as food inflation has raced past
50 percent
i found some items
about
three times more than even last week
yeah so it's always every day it's going
up
the person who bought kilos before now
buys 250 grams
things are at rock bottom
the united nations says the country's
economic crisis has affected food
security agriculture livelihoods and
access to health services
its world food program says three out of
four families are badly affected they're
cutting back on meals they're cutting
back on the portions of those meals and
they're buying food that's much cheaper
but much less nutritious the un and
non-government organizations are
appealing for almost 50 million dollars
for what they describe as life-saving
assistance to the worst-hit people but
there are bigger concerns
my fear is that there is a much larger
portion of the population who will very
soon need the same kind of assistance
unless there's a fundamental change in
the situation here
there's little sign of that at present
fuel supplies are running low
thousands of sri lankans queue for hours
sometimes days
energy minister kanchana vijay sakura
says he has no choice but to introduce a
weekly quarter for registered consumers
many people waiting in queues told al
jazeera they don't believe this will
work
another group fed up with shortages took
to the streets banging pots and pans and
kitchen utensils demanding president
gotaber rajapaksa and his latest
government step down
the government is trying desperately to
find a solution to the crisis but must
meet stringent conditions before it can
secure a bailout these don't mean much
for the tens of thousands of people
struggling to put food on the table mina
fernandez al-jazeera colombo